next category is achievement in short
subject here is a handsome couple who
produced two short subjects of their own
Janet Leigh and Tony Curtis this
marriage has worked out so well next
year they may use the same name Tony Lee
well that's show business here they are
damnit thank you
the nominees for best achievement in
cartoon short subjects are 90 night bugs
John W Burton producer Paul Bunyan Walt
Disney producer Sidney's family tree
William and wife's producer and the
winner is nighty night bugs John W
Burton
this is a terrific thrill for us at
Warner Brothers cartoons because it
means Bugs Bunny is finally made to
grade
he's tried for 18 years rabbit's feet
and all finally made it thank you I want
to pay the lion's share credit the Friz
Freleng the director the picture to his
immediate team Holly Pratt Warren Foster
Artie Davis Gary Shinichi Virgil Ross
and Tom O'Laughlin I want to give my
appreciation gratitude to Mel Blanc
who's the voice of Bugs Bunny as well as
many other characters and a marvelous
trooper and wonderful man and also the
mill Franklin our musical director inner
angel and about 75 other people that are
very talented and capable that Warner
Brothers cartoons that I don't know what
we'd do without legislation the nominees
for live-action short subjects are Grand
Canyon Walt Disney journey in the spring
Ian Ferguson the kiss John Patrick Hayes
snows of Iran the New Zealand screen
bored
George Prest associates t is for
tumbleweed James a Leventhal and the
winner mr. Curtis you mrs. goose thank
you Grand Canyon Walt Disney
on behalf of walls and the Disney gang
thank you very much